hier in der kalabrischen hauptstadt
catanzaro kämpft der staat gegen einen
übermächtigen feind kalabrien ist im
festen würgegriff der süditalienischen
mafia n'drangheta sie gilt als die
gefährlichste und mächtigste
mafia-organisation in europa experten
schätzen die gewinne der kriminellen
organisation auf rund 50 milliarden euro
pro jahr
die eigentliche summe höher sein die
sonne in germany locker in deutschland
gibt es viele geschäfte die von der
'ndrangheta geführt werden die mafia
struktur ist die gleiche wie in kabul
ihre aufgaben koks zu verkaufen und
damit neue legale geschäfts wege zu
eröffnen
der tod ist allgegenwärtig auch für die
mutter des getöteten matteo vinci
der junge mann hatte sich geweigert dem
manko so plant land das seit über 300
jahren im familienbesitz ist zu
überschreiben
sein todesurteil hier deswegen wurde
mein sohn getötet für 50 quadratmeter
land verhandelt wird seit dem 13 januar
in diesem gebäude gegen mehr als 350
mitglieder der größte gerichtssaal der
welt 355 angeklagte 913 zeugen sind
geladen
13.500 seiten umfasst die anklageschrift
was zu drei jahre könne prozess dauern
doch dass die ermittler in diesem
verfahren die strukturen der mafia
zerschlagen können ist unwahrscheinlich
[Musik]